volkov heads the russian mob that moved
into east berlin once the wall went up
at 61.
this guy has connections to cartels
throughout europe and the americas
neutralizing him will not only hurt
perseus but the global syndicate
he's a big fish and here's our little
fish
franz krauss according to mi6 he's one
of volkov's information couriers
he has a drop of folk off scheduled for
tomorrow night
we'll infiltrate east berlin via the
u-bond a ghost station on the other side
of the wall has the access point we need
from there we'll watch krauss as he
enters the city once falkoff shows his
face
it's killer capture
[Music]
berlin get ready
we're good to go
is
as soon as the train slows down you and
i'll jump off
part bizarre wait to the next station
bell and i'll track down krause all
right
train's slowing down let's go to work
all right here we go
careful these german guards still patrol
these abandoned stations
patrol ahead we can use a train to slip
past
movement on the platform
me
oh
come on this is the way out
[Music]
hey
nice work let's clean this up
crouch should be coming through the
checkpoints soon let's get to the
rooftop
park lazar we're almost in position copy
that
come on this way
careful the spotlight
i know how to lock a place down
[Music]
keep an eye on that checkpoint krause
will be coming through anytime
look for krause with your camera
damn security's even tighter than usual
if they detain krause he could miss his
meeting with falkoff
near the checkpoint man with the
briefcase is that him
good job that's our man that's krause
on me
oh
that
our intel says kraus and volkov will
meet at the bar across the street
is
find the contact
now look for the blue umbrella
vision the house is at the table over my
right shoulder
hudson didn't reveal much he said you're
after volkov
who knows the man's like a ghost i would
guess no more than a day
krause is so don't let his wholesome
appearance fool you
the man is a killer
one of my informants was picked up in a
random sweep just two blocks from here
the must assume there are more nearby
i would ask a favor of you he will not
hold up under torture for long
we need him rescued
they're holding him here
duncan
the bathroom i'll hold them up
team new plan meet outside cross's
apartment
he's still our ticket to bulk off
oh
us to come
i'm gonna need more time
rally up with lazar park without me i'll
update you when i can't
these [ __ ] knives
careful bell estas are everywhere
cup
b
we already have enough trouble
[Music]
my
i'll catch up with you when the heat
dies down
just let me go
please
i told you i'm not sure the sick i am
you i've seen
oh
i've been monitoring a nearby kgb field
house i
i don't know how they found me i've done
everything by the book
what did that paper say you you can't
trust these people
i don't even know what you're talking
about please just let me return to my
children
thank you for saving my life i'll be
waiting to hear from you
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
fish
oh
yes
people
uh
uh yeah
this is
good work i don't think anyone saw you
follow me
stay quiet we don't want the locals
riding us out
parks in the electronics store right
across the street from krauss's place
i was gonna pick her up some networks
from the bomb
closed already
[ __ ] is just up ahead
we're back a car pulled up near across
this building a few minutes ago but i
didn't have a good angle to
just a moment on the telephone
belt get eyes on cross
what do you think bizarre sounds like
volkov wants krause's briefcase
we should place a tracker in it the case
will lead us straight to walk off
one of us can sneak into kraus's
apartment avoiding kraus and his wife
might be the greater challenge
bell volunteers while he's doing that
i'll check around the exterior for any
unwanted guess park you can keep an eye
on us from here
i'll try to give you my best angle
[Music]
lovely
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
uh
[Music]
[Music]
uh
uh
[Music]
uh
[Music]
uh
[Music]
uh
[Music]
so
the stars are stopping everyone be
careful
bella saw krause right here see if you
can find it
if you're spotted by krauss or his wife
the mission is over
you can drink the wife if you have to
but kraus must go to the meeting
i'm about to phone krauss's apartment
get ready to enter
nice work now find the briefcase
and
[Music]
nice work now find the briefcase
[Music]
[Music]
she'll be out for hours clean it up
see you
nice work now find the briefcase
hello took me light here keep this kind
of freya
yeah this is
foreign
[ __ ] we missed the kid
papa poster
see you
[Music]
okay
have a look around
you're running out of time find a
briefcase
please
have you found the briefcase
understood just plant the tracker and
get out of there
huh
[Music]
huh
i can't explain how he got to the
material
but i brought him tooth that makes this
much less unblessed
has been looking for this one that percy
is
we have greater killer as well her own
colleague creditor
your spineless piece of [ __ ] uh i'm
sorry glitter the
kgp's pockets are deeper
fine
finally
perseus has a large bounty on your head
i don't care about your questions
unfortunately for you it seems these
friends of yours have other places to be
comrade
[Music]
i could probably make use of it but you
are damaged birds
only
get phone calls
[Music]
get on that line
big
don't kill him
[Music]
so here we are you and i
at last belle
on behalf of mi6 thank you
volkov is ours more than he deserves
now let's get the hell out of east
berlin
information from volkov confirms their
worst fears
perseus smuggled a nuclear device
through east berlin
we can't be certain of that yet he has
it i'm sure of it
we found encrypted geo coordinates with
volkov's nuclear intel
an unpopulated region within the soviet
republic of ukraine
an aerial recon run revealed this
i want to know everything that's going
on inside this building
we'll need the others for this one mason
woods will join us from kiev
bell you'll infill here with woods mason
and i will be standing by for an extract
sparkle handle comms
we have no idea how large or prepared
their forces will be so use discretion
if you have to engage
it's time we took a peek behind the iron
curtain
i'm not picking up any extra chatter
you're in the clear woods got me that
park
stay on comms keep mason and adler on
standby
let's go